un milliard de francs c'est le montant
débloqué par le gouvernement pour
satisfaire les infirmières leur nouveau
mouvement de grève a été massivement
suivie aujourd'hui à paris - en province
des négociations sont en cours entre la
coordination les infirmières les
syndicats et le ministre de la santé
françoise joly en grève et dans la rue à
paris elle était aujourd'hui de 25 mille
bus blanche à manifester leurs
revendications toujours la même une
augmentation de 2000 francs par mois
mais un conflit qui a surtout pour toile
de fond un débordement des syndicats
ceux ci se déclare seul habilité à
négocier avec le ministère de la santé
les infirmières en grève elle revendique
ses droits pour ce qu'elle appelle la
coordination un art spontané qui est à
l'origine de la grève représente que 5 %
de la profession donc sont obligés de
nous sommes incontournables la
modulation le ministère de la santé à
lui donner raison aux syndicats ce sont
eux et eux seuls qui se sont assis ce
soir à 18 heures autour de la table des
négociations
oui nous refusons cette participation de
la coordination pour trois raisons la
première c'est que pour négocier il faut
être élu et nous avons été élus le
transit au mois de mars dernier pour
représenter parce hospitalier la
deuxième raison c'est qu'un accord ça se
gère il faut être présent dans
l'ensemble des établissements pour le
faire appliquer et la troisième raison
c'est que la coordination est
aujourd'hui un phénomène parisien en ce
moment même ici au ministère de la santé
les négociations se poursuivent entre le
ministre claude evin et les syndicats
d'ores et déjà le ministère a proposé
une augmentation de 300 francs pour les
infirmières en début de carrière et 2100
francs pour celle en fin de carrière
soit après 34 ans de service des
propositions assorti de mesures de
formation
tout cela est chiffré à un milliard de
francs et des propositions qui reste
très en dessous de ce que réclament les
syndicats et la coordination des
infirmières une coordination toujours
exclu pour l'instant de ces négociations